I suppose I would go on for co that we
are all caught in webs of of power that
we perhaps not even aware of and that
whether we like it or not we are always
in a in a hierarchy of power where we
are both sort of being submitting to to
it and enforcing it ourselves and and I
was interested in this the nebulous
nature of of power and complicity in a
sense that guilt is never one
dimensional and that you know I think in
this day and age it's the concept of
evil is talked about any sort of black
and white terms but there's a lot of you
know very interesting theorists who have
looked at the concept of evil and you
know how the banality of evil is Hannah
Arendt would say or the sense that you
know ordinary people are capable of
extraordinary evil things so it's that
sense of the kind of the bleeding of of
power and capacity in it yeah we all are
in every single act that we that we do
we are somehow you know complicit in all
sorts of things and I guess that brings
up the issue of you know whether we are
more accountable for the sins of
commission or omission and I'm not sure
anyone really answers that question
this is part of the human condition that
we go through life hurting people and
that's you know we can't get away from
it but yeah I think it particularly
comes to a head in this age of
globalization where we are I'm really
connected in all these myriad ways that
are often invisible to us and so we've
in many ways I think lost saints and
lost side of the structures within which
we live and that's the you know that's
truly the it's a dangerous road to go
down I think where we've lost touch you
know not just from we've become
alienated certainly from the means of
production but I think also from as a
result and we've become less and less
accountable for the things we do because
they are more and more hidden from us
and I feel this a lot in America because
you know having sort of lived here now
through this this war in Iraq and having
seen really nothing changed at a
day-to-day level living your life in in
a country that's at war and that's a
particularly American thing right
there's never been conflict on this
piece of land except for the civil war
but it's that sense that these things
can be done in our names and yet so
invisible to us unless you seek them out
and so that we get lulled into a sense
of complacency and I'll true and the
blood that's on our hands is you know we
we don't see it but I do think it has
still has a corrupting effect and that
you can't help but have your moral
compass start to go awry when you
of things are being done in your name
whether you know it or not
her